we are very excited about our next guest
that's TV host and author caramo Brown
he became a household name this was back
in 2004 on the real world Philadelphia
look at you who y'all booked out the old
photos he was the first openly gay black
man cast on a reality show and now
caramo has his own daytime talk show
thank you very much guess what the name
of it is carabo
he's a culture expert on the Netflix
series queer eye he's also an author and
his newest book is called I am okay to
feel now he wrote this children's book
this is what's so great about it with
his son it tells the story of a father
and son who get caught in a storm
teaches young readers to share their own
feelings and their emotions and first on
CBS morning's caramo Brown joins us now
to discuss that and so many things
congratulations in Bravo thank you so
much this is great because you have your
own son and you your son have been
through some things we'll get to that in
a second yeah but the bottom line of
this is no storm lasts forever you say
never be embarrassed about your feelings
is silly it's okay to feel scared happy
angry or sad it's okay to feel and heal
now you said you wrote this in
particular for men black men in
particular yeah because you all seem to
have problems expressing you okay well
it's the way they do it was the way that
we were raised you know I mean like I
grew up in a household where it was
always man up you know show be strong
don't cry don't cry like you know and
all these these things it's like just
because I'm a man or just because I'm
African-American doesn't mean that I
don't have emotions that I want to
express right and um you know I always
tell people there was a story when I
played football I remember I fell hurt
myself the coach told me man up brown
and a girl fell right next to me and
everybody ran to her and helped her and
I was like what about me over here
bleeding you know what I mean this was
just a reminder that it's okay for us
all to feel our feelings and I love that
you did it with a little boy too in
particular I think that's the point yes
it is well especially being a father you
know my sons I'm raising two black boys
in America and there's so many things
that they're going through we went
through three 2020 where you know they
were constantly in fear of their lives
they were constantly fear of like their
health and it was like you can express
all those feelings it's okay this storm
won't last forever but it's all right to
talk about it so that we can start to
heal it yeah and writing the book with
Jason you listen we should say the back
story you didn't even know Jason was
your son I didn't you met when he was 10
and you were 26. a high school romance
and she didn't reveal it to you yeah
Tony and I had some questions we weren't
sure because so could you break this
down for us a little bit yes yes so um I
I came out as gay when I was 15. yeah
first high school girlfriend we were
best friends we said let's lose our
virginity each other I said girl you
know I'm gay she said it's okay being
young and foolish we went for it and
then you know this is 1995 so there was
no phone and internet right she moved
away oh okay okay you don't have a
forwarding address there's no IG yeah
there's no IG to follow up so yeah whoa
I know that's that's pretty
life-changing news but let me tell you
something I always believe that God has
a bigger and divine plan for me and so
that was part of the plan that I needed
to mature to be better it led my son to
becoming an author at a young age and
for us to be talking about this that's
awesome yeah so you now no longer use
the phrase I'm fine when people say how
are you I do not I gave up up of saying
I'm fine I think we're all in this sort
of generic mode to say I'm fine actually
it's automatically automatically and the
thing is because out of this sort of
guilt that I don't want to put my
pressure on you this sort of shame that
you know we're all taught to keep
everything in the household don't talk
about your feelings I don't want to
trauma I don't wanna I don't want to
trauma dump on you and it's like it's
okay to say to someone this is what I'm
feeling in the moment I don't need you
to solve it I'm not trying to Reign on
your day but you ask me how I'm feeling
and it's okay for me to get it out
before I go on with my day and so when
someone says how you doing I'm not like
if I'm not fine I'm not going to say I'm
fine yeah I'm gonna tell you how I'm
feeling you also don't seem
uncomfortable expressing your feelings
on the talk show you recently revealed
about Jason yeah that he that he almost
died and you almost witnessed him dying
an issue with drugs wow do you feel
uncomfortable sharing your your life
that way I don't because the thing is on
my show I deal with regular people
everyday people and I expect them to be
vulnerable so I expect me to be
vulnerable as well anything I expect
from them I do myself and you know
especially dealing with addiction it was
something that I should have I thought
that I should have known I had this
guilt over
um because I was like I should catch
this and I didn't catch it in my own
household and I did almost lose my son
during the pandemic to drugs and I
wanted other people to know that they
can make it through Jason's two years
sober now that's good I wanted yeah I
want them to know that like here are
resources I want to know parents like
sometimes you don't see all the signs
and that's okay and no storm lasts
forever no storm lasts forever that's
right now real quick what what message
do you want this book to send to adults
oh listen there's a couple X's I'm
sending this book too as well to be like
you know you need to feel your feelings
but it's for adults to know that they
can feel as well like yeah right yeah
feel your feelings as well caramel brown
we appreciate you I'm okay to feel is
available now wherever you like to buy
your books that's a nice way to end the
show thank you paramo we'll see you
tomorrow on CBS mornings take it easy